my first last and only sex ed class took
place in my eighth grade biology
teachers living room it's not as creepy
as it sounds but it is a scary see my
high school didn't allow us to be taught
sex ed on campus
it's my 28 classmates and I got our
permission slip signed run our coats and
walk the half mile up the road to dr.
Robbins house where we sat for an hour
squeezing couches listening to a sex ed
teacher
roll condoms onto bruised bananas one
conversation one form of contraception
four of my girlfriends from growing up
never made it to college they got
pregnant before we graduated I'm not
trying to draw a direct causal and cure
but I'm trying to make a point this is
crazy
in the u.s. 51 percent of pregnancies
every year are unplanned that's half by
the age of 45 more than half of American
women will have had an unplanned
pregnancy half so from you here on over
today congratulations you're expecting
now you don't need to have a uterus to
be a part of this conversation either
you could be friends with someone with
uterus you could be related to someone
with uterus or perhaps most importantly
you can be sleeping with someone with
uterus and this conversation matters for
you too so what's happening here why is
this happening
we're either not using contraceptives or
we're not using them effectively let's
take a hypothetical scenario let's say
everyone in this room is actually active
this is a hypothetical
say your chosen form of contraception is
a withdrawal method also known as
pulling prey over one year of typical
use 22 percent of us would become
pregnant say instead your chosen form of
contraception is a condom over one year
of typical use 18 percent of us would
still get pregnant say instead use a
pill pill is great everyone uses a pill
over one year of typical use nine
percent of us would still get pregnant
say instead you use an IUD an IUD is an
intrauterine device it's kind of
long-acting reversible contraceptive say
instead your chosen form of
contraception is an IUD over one year of
typical use 0.2 to 0.8 percent of us
would get pregnant if you get sterilized
the pregnancy rate is still point five
percent what I think is most interesting
about IUDs and I think a lot of things
are interesting about IUDs is a
difference in failure rates for
different kinds of birth control under
scenarios of perfect use ie how doctors
tell us we should use them and scenarios
of typical use ie
how we actually use them what sets the
IUD apart is what I like to call the set
it and forget it approach once you have
it inserted you don't have to think
about it again until you want it removed
awesome
we must be using these right wrong in
the u.s. less than 6 percent of women
use an IUD as their personal form of
contraception that is the lowest rate of
any developed country what is that why
in a country so used to being the best
on so many dimensions we're not using
the best and most effective form of
contraception there are a few reasons
for that but the one I want to talk
about today is the fact that we're not
talking about it we don't talk about sex
and contraceptions and reproductive
health in this country heck we leave
high school campuses just to say the
words that's led to an increase in
misinformation and a decrease in
awareness
about what the most effective forms of
contraception really are namely IUDs so
what can we do about it we can start the
conversation today I'm going to answer
three commonly held questions about IUDs
sit together we can start the
conversation about contraception so
first question what are these first I
want to be clear these are not ieave
ease the explosive devices these are
IEDs IUDs and treater and devices like
the one shown here there are three main
types in the US Mirena and Scylla which
are plastic like the one shown here and
Paragard like this one has copper wire
wrapped around it rainin Scylla worked
by releasing low-dose hormones in the
body the equivalent of less than one
birth control pill a week Fair Guard has
copper wire wrapped around it and has no
hormones and last in the body from - 10
to 12 years would you mind holding that
IUDs work by disrupting the flow of
sperm ability so that they're unable to
fertilize an egg among other mechanisms
they're easily inserted in the uterus
and a 15-minute procedure although some
women say it can be painful or
uncomfortable okay next question
aren't they dangerous the first
generation of IUD technology the Dalkon
shield came on the mark in the 1970s and
was responsible for a host of negative
health outcomes it was pulled from the
market but the stigma has persisted this
new generation of IUD technology is
incredibly safe although it is a medical
device so certain risks persist okay
fine but what do they cost I had to use
cost anywhere from 300 to 700 dollars
although many insurance plans cover them
in full if not for a small copay if we
take worst-case scenario $700 and
amortize that over the shortest time
period five years that works out to less
than $11 a month that's literally less
than the cost of lunch at Arbuckle our
dining hall you compare that to the cost
of sending an unplanned child to college
think that comparison is pretty clear so
they work they're safe and they're cost
effective now why aren't we using them
now it's time for a medical disclaimer
I'm not a doctor and this is not a
substitute for a conversation with a
medical professional
IUDs or medical device so carry with
them certain risks and some women are
also uncomfortable with a thought of a
foreign object in their body although
this whole conversation is predicated on
foreign objects in your body so
IUDs are part of a choice however
they're part of a choice that each
female makes and many couples make
together about their reproductive health
and if I you DS are missing from the
conversation then they're not a part of
that choice at all I want to ask you to
do something think of the name of one
person one person that you're going to
have a conversation with about
contraception in the next week it can be
your partner a friend a doctor a spouse
on the screen is the name of a website
you can go to for more information if
you want help starting this conversation
IUDs are one of the most effective forms
of contraception that exists and we're
not using them but we are having sex
it's time to start the conversation
about contraception together so that I
you DS can become a part of that choice
thank you
you
you